one of their favorite Sons were the
all-time greats two-time MVP Dale Murphy
he came with props and a Hank Aaron
Jersey and his own Jersey got to the
mound and then he broke out the Austin
Riley Jersey how about that also broke
out the pearls a necklace made of pearls
just like John Peterson wears you think
Dale Murphy's not locked in with the
Atlanta Braves got a huge Ovation very
cool moment before the game that's a big
bat out that's 13 postseason homers the
franchise record holder in postseason
home runs not available the right-hander
on the mound Ian Anderson he's already
shown up in a big way in the postseason
this is a young guy that has not been
afraid of the big Spotlight of the
playoffs here is Corey Seger on the
first pitch a high drive in the right
center field Peterson on the run this
ball is up and gone Corey Seeger a first
inning blast and the Dodgers strike
early tonight and the Dodgers continuing
the theme of first inning woes for Ian
Anderson so Cody Bellinger stands in
here's the 0-1 Bellinger hits it sharply
to center field right at Duvall and
that'll retire the side Max Scherzer at
age 37 Ronnie still a power pitcher
Braves know him well Scherzer got an
extra day he knocks the save his first
ever professional save in game five of
the division series
albies just lays the bat on it a little
soft liner to Seeger for the final out
of the Innings and Riley a breakout
season this year 303 with 33 home runs
107 runs batted in Scherzer Strikes Out
Austin Riley to start the second inning
[Applause]
for Seeger and he'll make the play going
down to his back stayed with it all the
way it's a long run with the shift on
Dodgers moved their third baseman on the
other side of the infield for Peterson
so that was Seeger's ball into town
number two
Scherzer deals the strike a called
strike three to win the inning third k
for Max Scherzer a couple of hits last
night he was three for 22 in the
division series against San Francisco
and he hits Howard sharply into left
center field long run it is going to be
caught Rosario
zari's minute stab at it and takes extra
bases away from Trey Turner it is
possible that Seeger scores if that gets
by Rosario for Ian Anderson you just had
two ropes hit off you and you get a
first pitch pop-up to give you two outs
now and again you're one pitch away from
getting out of this
at first down goes Taylor
a strikeout for Anderson on a changeup
went to his Bretton butter it's Jesse
Chavez out of the Atlanta Bullpen yeah
ending a two-thirds scoreless ball
against Milwaukee in the division series
Bellinger in the left field Rosario been
busy makes a play for out number one AJ
Pollock swings of the first pitch and a
chopper to third taken back to the bag
by Riley and his throw across is true
and two very quick outs for Chavez near
the top of the fourth inning so here is
Max Scherzer with two outs
and that's going to continue Chavez
makes a play nice quick inning for him
that's a six pitch inning one out base
runner here for Atlanta with Peterson
coming up see how sure their attacks
jock Peterson this time around last time
quite a few change-ups ended up hanging
one Jack Peterson just missed a home run
pitch from Scherzer swinging a deep
drive to right field
hit tremendous Force
Anderson he just sent another Pearl into
the Chop House
and it's two apiece here in the bottom
of the four
[Applause]
doubter well said just missed Going Up
on the Roof
ing was blasted
and once again jocktober here in Atlanta
it's unbelievable in the postseason 2-1
one ball two strikes on Gavin Lux he has
been the hot hand at the plate for the
Dodgers that's in Smith aboard and in
the air left field easy go over Rosario
Mentor a pop of the Fist he's out of the
inning chance of Freddy raining down two
on one away 2-2 pitch and a swing and a
miss seven in a row seven consecutive
case for Freddie Freeman for the
frustration mounting Rosario with a base
hit two that are on swats in the runner
at second he carries the go-ahead Run
here's a 2-2 again
a big strikeout and a motion just
pouring out of the left-hander now the
Dodgers have the go-ahead Run 90 feet
away with just one out here's a 2-2 a
swing he had a Miss he struck him out
five change UPS in a row Albert Pujols
we'll stand in for Los Angeles go ahead
and run a third and a swing of the Miss
nazic strikes him out
all right so the moves here Brian
Snicker the double switch Guillermo
Heredia takes over for Duvall in center
field Duvall is out Luke Jackson is in
Dodgers have been knocking at the door
seemingly in every inning Bases Loaded
two outs
[Applause]
is in Smith is in two run score for the
Dodgers
Taylor delivers a base hit and Los
Angeles is on top four to two a huge hit
for Chris Taylor
Peretti adjusts into the game their most
accomplished center fielder and he
couldn't quite get there the Braves will
bring the tying run to the plate and
guess who Freddie Freeman's coming up
Freeman in the air to left field gonna
stay up there for Pollock and he'll make
the play tagging is Rosario and he is
just in there good boy that was risky
now it's alby's there's the 0-1 and
that's how Basin in the right field
Rosario got a late start they're going
to wave him home the throw to the plate
oh my goodness oh one of the riskiest
sins you can have Ron Washington wound
him home and Rosario is just in there
RBI for all fees and it's a one-run game
you know you get Austin Riley coming up
one run game eighth inning 4-3 game
Maria's deals
in the center field
some heat on it
the head of the center fielder bets
always around third throwing to the
plate and we are tied Austin Riley the
king of Atlanta delivers again walk off
last night game tying double here in the
eight well there's two outs and you got
good speed at second so the key for
Dansby is get a good lead and with two
out be off at the crack of the bat the
Dodgers are going to ship offering to
Rosario
line drive that is through it gets
through here comes Dansby lightning
strikes twice and the Braves walk it off
this is unbelievable and the Braves win
it and they go up two nothing in the
series listen
I can't believe it
Michelob Ultra organic Seltzer as real
as it tastes